the big news this morning is that the
inflation numbers were released for
september as we have been telling you
non-stop since last year inflation is
not transitory the cpi number came in at
5.4 percent this is a 13 year high the
cpi the core or i'm sorry the consumer
price index is as high as it was during
the financial crisis absolutely insane
core inflation came in at four percent
if you see here we have first the tweet
u.s september consumer prices increased
5.4
from one year earlier core cpi up four
percent over a year we'll get to core in
a second and the nonsense that that is
but first let's start with the consumer
price index five point four percent is
that crazy is it not well let's look on
a relative basis if we look around the
world and all of the different in cpi
numbers they're year over year percent
change what we find is that the us sucks
simple
just real simple the us sucks the only
countries that are doing better from an
inflation standpoint are venezuela
argentina turkey brazil russia mexico
and poland the united states sucks our
inflation is higher than places like the
philippines or india maybe even
australia new zealand sweden finland
hong kong portugal indonesia saudi
arabia and japan the u.s inflation is
absolutely absurd over 5.4 percent
people in the philippines and south
africa are better off than they are here
in the united states when it comes to
cpi so what exactly does that mean well
if we go ahead and we look at cpi
over five percent like this what we see
is that for four months in a row cpi has
now been over five percent what exactly
is transitory transitory is a word that
you cannot measure does transitory mean
it's only one month two months three
months four months well could it be a
year could it be six months how do you
determine what transitory is that is the
reason why they're using that term is
there is no way to quantify but cpi has
now been above five for four months in a
row the last time that happened was in
the mid 90s
and in the 2008 financial crisis so you
can say all you want it's transitory or
it's not what we know is that cpi at
over five percent is absolutely
punishing the bottom 45 percent of
americans remember when there are high
rates of inflation like there are right
now what we find is that people who hold
investments who hold assets they are
making more money than they ever dreamed
of everyone's getting rich if you're an
investor if you hold assets the asset
prices are being pumped to the moon by
monetary and fiscal policy
the people who hold no investments those
that live paycheck to paycheck or have
100 of their net worth in cash which is
the bottom 45 percent of americans they
get punished by this not only are they
experiencing the same high levels of
inflation of over 5.5
or 5.4 percent but they also usually
make a majority of the purchases
of their monthly budgets in inflationary
goods so things like rent and food make
up the majority of the things that they
purchase on a monthly basis and those
happen to be some of the most
inflationary goods so if you are in the
bottom 45 you have no investments you
get punished by the politicians and
central bankers who continue to go on
television and in front of different
hearings etc and they pair at the
talking points of don't worry
inflation's not bad don't worry it's in
uh transitory don't worry it'll come
down don't worry it's only in used cars
or don't worry it's only in food or it's
only in rent
no the everyday american feels this
they're watching everything around them
get more and more and more expensive and
it's not transitory it's not been going
on for four months we're talking about a
situation that remember
only started in march of 2020 the
recession ended more than a year ago
a year later we still have over five
percent persistent inflation you can say
it's transitory all you want you can try
to manipulate words you can try to hide
the facts but what we find is that the
everyday person knows what's going on
because they feel it now we continue on
and we look at actually what is driving
the inflation what we find is that there
are a number of different parts of the
economy that are part of these consumer
prices that are actually driving most of
this so if we go ahead and we look that
the rate of change remember prices rose
0.4 in september they only rose point
three percent in august so it actually
has gotten worse
than it was in august so do not be
tricked by anything you are reading it
is actually getting worse rather than it
is getting better if we go ahead and we
look at these items on an itemized basis
what we see is that food on an
unadjusted 12 month period
food is up 4.6
that means that if you go and you buy
food
it now cost you 4.6 more if you did not
receive a bump in pay whether to a
salary or to your hourly rate of more
than 4
literally they are stealing from you
because the food that you need to eat to
survive to be a human now cost more than
it did 12 months ago and that is
ultimately why inflation is theft and so
if we go ahead and we look here the food
at home is up 4.6
food away from home is up 4.5 it doesn't
matter where you're eating food is up if
we then look at the really big ones
energy energy is up significantly up
almost 25
if we look at things around gasoline the
gasoline is up 42
coming in with just massive massive
numbers if we then go down and we look
at used cars up 24.4 percent new
vehicles up eight percent and all
commodities minus food and energy up
seven percent absolutely nuts
transportation up four point four
percent doesn't matter if you're buying
a new car a used car or using other
modes of transportation it is all up
significantly and so what we are
watching is we are watching the death of
the middle class and we are also
watching the punishment of anyone who is
not educated enough to actually buy
assets if you do not have the financial
education that is necessary to
understand to spend less money than you
make to take the leftover reserves make
some sort of kind of cash uh safety net
create one two three four five six
months of a safety net and then take
every single dollar that you possibly
have and get it invested in the market
you are actually becoming poor over time
the cash that is sitting in your bank
account is being eroded away
by this type of absolute insanity so we
then go and we look at holger
tweet here he said oops u.s consumer
prices outpace the forecast remember why
is it that the forecast is always wrong
they're never right because they don't
know what they're doing headline cpi
rose 5.4 versus what was expected at 5.3
it got worse faster than they thought
which matches the largest annual gain
since 2008 but remember if you exclude
the volatile food and energy components
so-called core inflation rose four
percent now in this chart specifically
you can see that the yellow line is the
cpi and the white line is core now core
is absolutely ridiculous measurement why
well lynn alden absolutely coming off
the top rope between the legs 360 dunk
if they don't need to eat use energy or
need some sort of home inflation's
declining no problem don't worry about
it basically core inflation measures
nonsense it is an absolute stupid metric
and the reason why it's a stupid metric
it's because the core things that you
need to buy are not minus eating energy
and shelter instead the things that you
actually need are food energy and
shelter and so maybe what we should
actually be talking about is what is the
majority of purchases that you make food
energy and shelter so what's happening
in those and if they were to separate
out those three things what we would
find is they're way worse
than
actually taking them out so pretty crazy
now when i talk about this everyone says
okay there's all these numbers all these
numbers are floating around cpi core i
don't know i don't pay attention i'm not
smart i don't care about inflation well
yes you do why miles suiter coming again
with a great chart in statistics here
the wealth disparity blows out according
to the fed total wealth by wealth
category and trillions of dollars what
we find is that going all the way back
to 1995
you can see that the top 10
their wealth has exploded
and the bottom 50 has basically stayed
the same they've been pushed down
unnecessarily now why is that occurring
when you see the top 10
exploding after 2008 and you see that
bottom 50 percent just staying flat to
down why is that happening it's simply
because they're devaluing the currency
and the people who own assets
their wealth is not being devalued
instead it's actually being increased in
value so if i have a piece of real
estate and the dollar is being devalued
and i bought it in 2008 for let's say a
hundred thousand dollars and they
continue to devalue the currency if i do
nothing to the property i make no
improvements i do nothing to it i simply
hold it all of a sudden in 2020 i could
actually just sell it for
150 000 i mean 50
on the real estate it did nothing i
simply just held it i was out of dollars
and the dollar got devalued now somebody
else needs 50 more dollars to buy that
same piece of property that i bought
years ago this is what the wealthy know
that those who are not wealthy do not it
is not anything to do
taxes and all this nonsense you can turn
a good situation into a great situation
but if you do not have the basic
knowledge to understand you cannot hold
cash because they will devalue the hell
out of it and that you must get invested
in markets again the market that you
invested doesn't even matter everything
goes up over time as long as they
continue to devalue the currency whether
you are holding equities or stocks
whether you're holding commodities real
estate bitcoin it all goes up and to the
right over long periods of time because
they continue to devalue the currency
and they have only accelerated it is
devaluing at an absolutely historic rate
now as if anyone doesn't believe that
inflation is high the social security
department has decided that they are
going to increase what they are going to
pay to social security recipients they
are going to increase it 5.9
in 2022 as the fed effectively caps that
mortgage rate at about three percent so
when we start to think about this you
can actually look and say wait a minute
why is it that the official inflation
numbers are coming in at five point four
percent or four percent core all these
other numbers that make it look like
they can argue oh it's transitory don't
worry but the social security
department's gonna pay you more than
that
sure that's a good thing for those
people but the truth is that the actual
inflation is not 5.4 percent there is
nobody nobody who works at the federal
reserve nobody who's an economist nobody
who works on wall street nor anybody who
works in the mainstream media who
actually believes the official inflation
number is 5.4 percent they know that the
i'm sorry the actual inflation is 5.4
the official number is 5.4 but we have
heard over and over and over again
whether it's economists whether it's
jerome powell and others talk about the
unofficial inflation rate and the reason
is because they are taking bad data
they're using bad
actual analysis of that data to get to
that 5.4 percent you cannot manipulate
the data and actually think that it
represents what's actually occurring
remember when you look at things like
the rent increase they still are trying
to explain to us that the rent increases
in america are around two percent year
over year but yet we have the actual
data platforms like zillow or
apartment.com telling us that they are 8
to 14
as just one example and so today what we
are seeing is again a reminder that the
only thing you can do to protect
yourself is you have to invest you
cannot save your wealth your way to a
life of financial security you must
actually invest to be able to do it
jerome powell said that there's no
impact from the fed's decisions on the
wealth inequality gap because nobody's
come into his office and told him that
there's a wealth inequality gap that's
driven by the fed's uh policy i mean
stanley druckenmiller one of the best
investors on wall street openly just
went on uh cnbc a couple of weeks ago
and was like the fed is responsible for
the increase in the wealth inequality
gap they're the number one driver of the
wealth inequality guy so i don't know
what they're listening i don't know if
they put on noise cancelling headphones
or something but literally hey wake up
federal reserve you guys are responsible
for the wealth inequality gap literally
you are basing all of your decisions on
theory that's not how the real world
works what we are watching is 45 percent
of americans hold no investments and so
while you pump asset prices and half of
your fed presidents are day trading
enriching themselves to the tune of
millions of dollars over the last 12 to
18 months you've punished 45 million
americans which is literally about 150
million people are worse off because you
guys are making stupid decisions well
you've literally enriched yourself